hmm yes I'm let's meet you hi guys we
are hot are we camping we kind of like
radical yachting getting where yachting
cuz why not
I'm very bad of all your life your life
your life instead of hot guys you're
like you're like I'm like filming it's
coming up with like the time that's all
right
yes the red dot I know I love a charge
that's my orbit reason where my country
let's chat
[Music]
shouldn't walk behind horses because
they make fun but we need to get out oh
great he's pooping on my exists if he
hoping he might react supermodel I don't
know what is it doing now
[Music]
no I actually thought only when I was
saying that it might be watching check
out where we're making our dinner right
now it's in a bus it's in a bad what is
it's pretty cool order that it's all of
it - like it's like a bun oh no we've
got the bel-air thing I can't maintain I
don't know what I saw Cydia light in
here cuz there are like buses like most
like like wishes for Paris you guys is
our michael fun like your liking I had a
light bulb I like rich hello YouTube
know about it is that the red one or the
green one you know that's door closing
before you came from a campaign planting
another glamping cooking good everyone
cooking dinner in the kitchen trailer I
wonder where Laura is and found this
whole crisis do your job
okay focus company horrible popular my
rocky Idol button yes Kassadin face not
survive
[Music]
[Laughter]
and here we have the are addicts with
her ginger hair so fringy hippie
cardigan a katie jumper and katie shots
of the classic yakima legs
knee-high sorry high socks and fluffy
socks combo with some shoes that she's
probably going to fall over in a minute
oh wait you just do some juice that's
okay this one is giving in and out and
here's Laura with a classic I want to
dipose for Lois
if I'm a map in your chest commotion on
my mouth
[Music]
[Music]